[Music]
i have a story i'd like to tell you okay
in addition to having my own show
i'm also a writer at late night with
seth meyers and four years ago
john lutz and i wrote a sketch for that
show that no one has ever seen
we wrote a sketch about what it was
going to feel like when hillary clinton
won the election because
we were so sure she was going to win and
seth meyers was so sure that when we
turned it in he was like yes
go ahead and shoot this and the rest of
the staff was so sure that everyone
immediately got to work making it happen
they built
sets and designed costumes and hired a
bunch of actors and
we got up early on election day and shot
it
that's how i spent election day four
years ago
shooting a sketch about hillary clinton
winning
that is how sure i was that she would
win and
later that night when our editors
finished putting it all together
we knew for sure that she would not win
so
they filed it away and we never showed
it to anyone
well i'd like to show it to you now so
just to give you a sense of where we
were all at four years ago this week
i want you to watch this video and just
a quick note when you watch it
you'll notice that there are a bunch of
tv screens with nothing on them
okay that's because we were going to go
back later and add actual
news footage of hillary clinton winning
we put
a bunch of these tv screens in there
because
again that's how sure we were that she
was going to win
so when you watch this video and you see
a screen
it is empty because it would have had
hillary clinton winning on it
and she did not so to remind you where
we were at this time four years
ago okay it felt like trump hated women
so badly that we couldn't understand how
any woman
worked with him and everyone was
threatening to leave the country and
the thought of having a woman president
was our heart's
joy and we could not imagine the four
years we were about to have
okay are you guys ready to have some
feelings
all right blank screen is hillary
winning okay
all right take a look
[Music]
yes
oh yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
oh grandma
[Music]
oh thank god
[Music]
[Music]
yay
[Music]
so
don't you dick
[Music]
[Music]
i show this video to you today to say
please whatever you can do
please do it do anything vote talk to
people go door to door
text bank phone bank dip into your own
bank and give
take a picture going like this with the
caption v is for vote [ __ ] and put it
on instagram i don't know
but please do something because the way
i feel whenever i watch
this video i don't want to feel that
again next week
let's all do whatever we can this
election and then on november 4th
let's re-watch this video and laugh and
laugh and laugh
and then maybe seth won't make me pay
him back for hiring all those children
deal all right
[Music]
you